Save now at Whole Foods Market. It's the Summer Splash event, with great everyday prices on 365 brand ground beef for the grill and ice cream for dessert. They have yellow sales signs on ready to cook beef or chicken kebabs too. Level up with savory marinate, spices and rubs, and complete your cookout with a crowd-pleasing cherry pie and their balsamic chicken salad. Available at the prepared foods counter. Get Summer Splash Savings now at Whole Foods Market. What makes for a good life? You might think that the best life would be one of unadulterated happiness,
现在就去全食超市（Whole Foods Market）省钱吧。夏季清凉活动正在进行中，365品牌的烧烤用碎牛肉和餐后甜点冰淇淋都有超值的日常优惠。他们还为即烹牛肉或鸡肉烤串贴上了黄色促销标签。用美味的腌料、香料和干腌料来提升口感，再配上一份广受欢迎的樱桃派和香醋鸡肉沙拉，让你的户外烧烤更加完美。这些商品在熟食柜台均有销售。现在就去全食超市享受夏季清凉优惠吧。什么才是美好生活？你可能认为最好的生活就是纯粹的幸福，
where moments of pain and suffering never intrude on your comfort and joy. But why then do people often seek out hardship? Many of us like to watch scary movies or listen to songs that make us cry. We choose to run marathons and to raise children, even though both of those pursuits inevitably come with struggle and pain. Why do we do these things? What do we get out of the pain? do we get out of the pain and suffering that we choose to experience? What does it add to our lives?
在这种生活中，痛苦和磨难的时刻永远不会侵扰你的舒适与快乐。但为什么人们又常常寻求磨难呢？我们许多人喜欢看恐怖电影或听让我们流泪的歌。我们选择跑马拉松和养育孩子，尽管这两项追求都不可避免地伴随着挣扎和痛苦。我们为什么要这样做？我们从痛苦中得到了什么？我们从选择经历的痛苦和磨难中得到了什么？它给我们的生活增添了什么？
And what about pain that we don't choose? Do illness, poverty, or the death of a loved one add meaning to our lives? Does unchosen suffering make us better, stronger, or more moral? Or is it always a bad thing? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. Our guest today is Dr. Paul Bloom, a professor of psychology at the University of Toronto, and the Brooks and Suzanne Reagan Professor Emeritus of Psychology at Yale University. His most recent book is The Sweet Spot, The Pleasures of Suffering and the Search for Meaning.
那么我们没有选择的痛苦呢？疾病、贫困或亲人的离世会给我们的生活增添意义吗？未被选择的苦难会让我们变得更好、更强大或更有道德吗？还是说它总是一件坏事？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。我们今天的嘉宾是多伦多大学心理学教授、耶鲁大学心理学荣誉退休教授保罗·布鲁姆博士。他最近出版的书是《甜蜜点：苦难的乐趣与意义的追寻》。
More broadly, he studies how children and adults make sense of the world with a special focus on pleasure, morality, religion, fiction, and art. He is co-editor of the journal Behavioral and Brain Sciences, And in addition to scientific publications, he writes for popular outlets, including the New York Times, The Atlantic, and the New Yorker. Thank you for joining us today, Dr. Bloom. Thank you for having me, Kim. And that was a wonderful introduction.
更广泛地说，他研究儿童和成人如何理解世界，特别关注快乐、道德、宗教、小说和艺术。他是《行为与脑科学》杂志的联合编辑，除了科学出版物外，他还为《纽约时报》、《大西洋月刊》和《纽约客》等大众媒体撰稿。感谢您今天加入我们，布鲁姆博士。谢谢你的邀请，金。那是一个非常精彩的介绍。
Great. Well, we're going to be talking about a lot of those. So let's start first by talking about what you mean by suffering. That's a pretty strong word. And some people might think that an experience must be really terrible in order to be categorized as suffering. But you take a wider view. So what's your definition? Yeah, I think it's important. It's a good question. It's important for us to be clear what we're talking about. Some people only use suffering to refer to real heavy duty experiences. And I'm very interested in those. I'm very interested in extremes of pain or anguish. But the puzzle I sort of set myself to solving is why we pursue suffering in a broader sense. So it includes the pain you might experience you running a marathon, a BDSM, it includes effort, including severe effort, but also milder stuff.
太好了。嗯，我们将讨论其中的许多内容。所以让我们先从你所说的“苦难”的含义谈起。这是一个相当强烈的词。有些人可能认为，一种经历必须非常糟糕才能被归类为苦难。但你采取了更广阔的视角。那么你的定义是什么？是的，我认为这很重要。这是一个好问题。我们需要明确我们在谈论什么。有些人只用“苦难”来指代真正沉重的经历。我对这些非常感兴趣。我对极端的痛苦或苦恼非常感兴趣。但我试图解决的难题是，为什么我们在更广泛的意义上追求苦难。所以它包括你在跑马拉松时可能经历的痛苦、BDSM，它包括努力，包括艰苦的努力，但也包括更温和的事情。
Why do we like chicken vindalue or spicy foods? Why do we like the effort of a crossword puzzle? And so if somebody says, oh, those aren't, that's not suffering in my heavy duty sense. I totally agree. I'm using suffering in a broader sense. So we're a little bit limited then by our language, right? I mean, English doesn't have many nuances for those types of strains that we place on ourselves. That's right.
为什么我们喜欢印度咖喱鸡或辛辣食物？为什么我们喜欢填字游戏的努力？所以如果有人说，哦，那些不是，那不是我所理解的那种沉重的苦难。我完全同意。我是在更广泛的意义上使用“苦难”这个词。所以我们的语言限制了我们，对吧？我的意思是，英语对于我们施加在自己身上的那些压力并没有太多的细微差别。没错。
I was trying to think of another single word, bad experiences, as close as I could come to it. I'm kind of another way of putting it is, if we don't want to use the word suffering at all, I'm interested in why we voluntarily expose ourselves to experiences that under normal circumstances we would avoid. So typically pain, effort, struggle, emotional anguish are bad. We want to avoid them. The puzzle I'm interested in is why do we sometimes seek them up? Well, why do you believe then that some pain and suffering are necessary in life? When I started writing this book, I had one answer in mind, which was, I was very interested in role of pain and suffering as a source of pleasure.
我试着想另一个词，“糟糕的经历”，这是我能想到的最接近的词了。换句话说，如果我们根本不想用“苦难”这个词，我感兴趣的是为什么我们自愿让自己接触那些在正常情况下我们会避免的经历。通常情况下，痛苦、努力、挣扎、情感苦恼都是坏事。我们想避免它们。我感兴趣的难题是，为什么我们有时会主动寻求它们？那么，你为什么认为生活中某些痛苦和磨难是必要的呢？当我开始写这本书时，我脑子里有一个答案，那就是，我对痛苦和磨难作为快乐源泉的作用非常感兴趣。
You know, why do we get a kick out of it? Why do we get a kick out of, you know, spicy foods and BDS and BDSM and all sorts of things, scary movies? But as I began to write the book and read and talk to people and think about this, I made an argument that there's something else going on. I think something deeper, which is we're not only interested in pleasure. And some of the voluntary pain and suffering and struggle we pick up is in certain. service of other goals like morality or like having a meaningful life, having a life of transcendent
你知道，为什么我们能从中获得快感？为什么我们能从辛辣食物、BDSM、各种各样的事情、恐怖电影中获得快感？但当我开始写书、阅读、与人交谈并思考这个问题时，我提出了一个论点，即还有其他事情在发生。我认为更深层的东西是，我们不仅对快乐感兴趣。我们选择的一些自愿的痛苦、磨难和挣扎，是为了实现其他目标，比如道德，或者拥有一个有意义的生活，拥有一个超越性的生活。
value. So let's dig into the connection then between suffering and pleasure just a little bit more. It touches on several things that I mentioned in the intro like watching horror movies, listening to sad songs on a more extreme. And you've talked about BDSM. I just want to tell some of our vanilla listeners that that refers to bondage, dominance, submission, sadomasochism, sexual practices. which you talk about at length in the book, you delve into several possible explanations for why so many of us seem to actually enjoy doing the things that bring us either physical or emotional pain.
价值。那么，让我们再深入探讨一下苦难与快乐之间的联系。它触及了我在介绍中提到的几件事，比如看恐怖电影、听悲伤的歌曲，在更极端的层面上。你谈到了BDSM。我只想告诉我们一些“香草”（普通）听众，这指的是束缚、支配、服从、施虐受虐，即性行为。你在书中对此进行了详细讨论，你深入探讨了为什么我们许多人似乎真的喜欢做那些给我们带来身体或情感痛苦的事情的几种可能解释。
So what are the fundamental reasons for that in your view? Yeah. I should also say I'm kind of a vanilla person myself. And so I end up talking about experiences that I end up reading about but not necessarily participating. And just to clear that one up. I think there are many ways in which suffering can give us pleasure. And a lot of my book is review of the work of other psychologists and neuroscientists and philosophers. One way is contrast.
在你看来，其根本原因是什么？是的。我也应该说，我自己也是一个“香草”类型的人。所以我最终谈论的是我读到过但并不一定参与的经历。只是为了澄清这一点。我认为苦难给我们带来快乐的方式有很多种。我的书很大一部分是对其他心理学家、神经科学家和哲学家的研究的回顾。其中一种方式是对比。
So we tend to judge and experience things not as absolute, but relative to what's gone before, relative to what we're expecting. And sometimes, I think the pleasure of something can be in terms, can we establish suffering and difficulty and pain because it feels so good when we stop. the bite of hot curry is painful in and of itself, but then you drink this cool beer and you feel really good. You go for a hard run, then you stop. He feels great. The bath is hot, but then it's just right. And so some of it's contrast.
所以我们倾向于判断和体验事物，不是作为绝对的，而是相对于之前发生的事情，相对于我们所期望的。有时，我认为某件事的快乐可能在于，我们建立苦难、困难和痛苦，因为当我们停止时感觉太好了。热咖喱的辛辣本身是痛苦的，但当你喝下这杯冰啤酒时，你会感觉非常好。你进行了一次艰苦的跑步，然后你停下来。他感觉棒极了。洗澡水很烫，但随后就刚刚好。所以其中一些是对比。
Some of it's the pleasure of mastery. You know, you put yourself in a difficult situation, you know, running is a good example or something scary, and you cope with it and you feel satisfaction that you're coping with it. Some of it, just to go to BDSM, because Roy Balmeister's theory BDSM is that it's an escape from the self. And you might think that's kind of a weird, voodooy way of talking about it. But sometimes our self-consciousness, our self-thoughts are unpleasant,
其中一些是掌握的快乐。你知道，你让自己处于一个困难的境地，你知道，跑步就是一个很好的例子，或者是一些可怕的事情，你应对它，你对自己的应对感到满足。其中一些，就拿BDSM来说，因为罗伊·鲍迈斯特关于BDSM的理论是，这是一种对自我的逃避。你可能认为这是一种谈论它的奇怪的、巫术般的方式。但有时我们的自我意识、我们的自我思想是不愉快的，
and good, sharp, sudden pain is often a way of clearing our head. And so those are sort of three stories into our others as to why we might get pleasure of the pain. So you also talk in the book about the difficult things we do that we don't necessarily enjoy, some of which you've just articulated. Why do we find meaning in pushing ourselves to climb mountains and run marathons? And is actual suffering an essential part of that? Is there no meaning if there's no suffering? I think there's no meaning if there's no suffering, or at least if there's not a chance of suffering. I think our common sense notion of a meaningful activity is one that that has challenges and difficulties and struggling.
而尖锐、突然的痛苦往往是一种清空我们大脑的方式。所以这些是关于为什么我们可能从痛苦中获得快乐的三种说法。那么，你在书中也谈到了我们所做的那些我们并不一定享受的困难事情，其中一些你刚才已经阐述过了。为什么我们在推动自己攀登高峰和跑马拉松时找到了意义？实际的苦难是其中的重要组成部分吗？如果没有苦难，就没有意义吗？我认为如果没有苦难，或者至少如果没有苦难的可能性，就没有意义。我认为我们对有意义活动的常识性概念是那些具有挑战、困难和挣扎的活动。
It's very difficult, I think, impossible things are saying, wow, this is a very meaningful thing I do, and it's totally easy. This is why, you know, sitting on a sofa watching Netflix isn't meaningful, but climbing a mountain might be. It's why, you know, a nice nap isn't meaningful, but having children might be. And it's an important distinction because when we engage in certain activities, I don't think we're actually seeking out suffering and pain. I say, I want to run a triathlon.
这非常困难，我认为，不可能的事情是说，哇，我做的这件事非常有意义，而且完全轻松。这就是为什么，你知道，坐在沙发上看Netflix并不意味着有意义，但爬山可能是有意义的。这就是为什么，你知道，小睡并不意味着有意义，但生孩子可能是有意义的。这是一个重要的区别，因为当我们参与某些活动时，我不认为我们实际上是在寻求苦难和痛苦。我说，我想参加铁人三项。
They're running a marathon, say. And when I want to run it, I'm actually hoping to have a great experience. I'm not seeking out blisters and sprained ankles and struggle and disappointment. But without the possibility of pain and difficulty, there'd be no enjoyment, no deeper satisfaction. So, yeah, I think the summits and suffering and meaning are inextricably linked. Do people who have more meaning in their lives than usually have less day-to-day happiness, or can you kind of maximize both? You can maximize both.
比如跑马拉松。当我想要跑的时候，我实际上是希望获得一次很棒的体验。我并不是在寻求水泡、扭伤的脚踝、挣扎和失望。但如果没有痛苦和困难的可能性，就不会有享受，也不会有更深层的满足感。所以，是的，我认为顶峰、苦难和意义是密不可分的。那些生活中更有意义的人通常日常幸福感更少吗？还是说你可以两者兼得？你可以两者兼得。
There's been some very nice research, and again, there's work by Baumaster and Kathleen Boss and their colleagues, where they ask people about how happy your life is and how meaningful your life is and ask all sorts of questions. And one finding is that these things are not essentially in opposition. In fact, they're correlated. somebody who says their life is happy, is more likely than not to say their life is meaningful and vice versa. But at the same time, they're not one and the same. So they looked at people who say they have happy lives versus very happy lives versus very meaningful lives. And the people who say
有一些非常好的研究，同样，有鲍迈斯特和凯瑟琳·沃斯及其同事的工作，他们询问人们生活有多幸福，生活有多有意义，并询问各种各样的问题。一个发现是，这些事情本质上并不对立。事实上，它们是相关的。一个说自己生活幸福的人，更有可能说自己的生活是有意义的，反之亦然。但与此同时，它们并不完全相同。所以他们观察了那些说自己生活幸福的人，与非常幸福的人，与非常有意义的人。而那些说
they have very meaningful lives report more anxiety, more struggle, more difficulty, more stress, they didn't have more children. They might be happy, but they're struggling. Well, there are people who claim to have very happy lives whose lives contain comparative relatively less struggle and difficulty. Your book also talks about the connection between suffering and morality, the idea that if you do something that in any way benefits yourself, people won't see it as altruistic or good. So where does this idea come from that doing good has to somehow hurt, has to be painful?
他们生活非常有意义的人报告了更多的焦虑、更多的挣扎、更多的困难、更多的压力，他们并没有更多的孩子。他们可能很幸福，但他们正在挣扎。嗯，有些人声称拥有非常幸福的生活，他们的生活中包含的挣扎和困难相对较少。你的书还谈到了苦难与道德之间的联系，即如果你做了一件以任何方式对自己有益的事情，人们就不会认为它是利他的或好的。那么，这种认为做好事必须以某种方式伤害、必须痛苦的想法是从哪里来的呢？
I don't know where it comes from, but I know it's true. There's some nice research by colleagues and friends of mine, Adelian Kane and George Newman, who were at Yale with me, who they have discovered, talk about what they call tainted altruism. And it turns out that, and there's real world examples, let's be do this in the lab, that people who do good but kind of enjoy it and gain something from it, we don't think there is good people. We like our people who do good to suffer.
我不知道它从哪里来，但我知道它是真的。我的同事和朋友阿德里安·凯恩和乔治·纽曼（他们曾和我一起在耶鲁大学）进行了一些很好的研究，他们发现了，谈论他们所谓的“受污染的利他主义”。事实证明，而且有现实世界的例子，让我们在实验室里做这个，人们做善事但从中享受并获得一些东西，我们并不认为他们是好人。我们喜欢我们做好事的人受苦。
And this shows up, this shows up, you know, shows up in the charities we do. So you ever ask yourself, why are there like fun runs? why do people pour ice water over your heads to raise money for treatments for ALS? Why don't they have fun massages or why don't they eat chocolate cuisants to raise money for ALS? Well, the answer is for whatever quirk of our heads, we relate suffering and morality. So, you know, if all of a sudden I want to raise money for a good cause, they're got to be suffering in it. It rings true in so many ways and it's really hard to put my finger on why. I mean, years ago, I did an AIDS ride, for example, you know, 300 miles over three days.
这表现在，这表现在，你知道，表现在我们参与的慈善活动中。所以你有没有问过自己，为什么会有像“趣味跑”这样的活动？为什么人们把冰水倒在头上为ALS（肌萎缩侧索硬化症）的治疗筹款？为什么他们不通过有趣的按摩或吃巧克力牛角面包来为ALS筹款？嗯，答案是，无论我们大脑有什么怪癖，我们将苦难和道德联系在一起。所以，你知道，如果我突然想为一个好的事业筹款，其中必须有苦难。它在很多方面都让人产生共鸣，而且我真的很难说清楚为什么。我的意思是，几年前，我参加了一次艾滋病骑行，例如，你知道，三天骑行300英里。
And, I mean, that was a killer. And, yeah, I raised money and I also had a great sense of achievement. You know, if I had just walked for three days, I probably would have been painful, too, but riding a bike for three days, man, that was a killer. I hear you say this, and I think you're a great person. And if you told me, oh, to raise money for this worthy cause, instead, you participated, you lay in your sofa and you watch. HBO and bank beer, I think, okay, it's kind of something, but no, you're not as good a person.
而且，我的意思是，那真是要命。而且，是的，我筹到了钱，我也有一种巨大的成就感。你知道，如果我只是走了三天，那可能也会很痛苦，但骑自行车三天，天哪，那真是要命。我听到你这么说，我觉得你是一个很棒的人。如果你告诉我，哦，为了这个值得的事业筹款，你反而参与了，你躺在沙发上看HBO喝啤酒，我想，好吧，这算什么，但不行，你不是一个那么好的人。
Well, let's talk for a minute about the difference between chosen and unchosen suffering. Terrible things happen to people all the time. People get ill. They're victims of violence. Their loved ones die. And there's a theory that's become popular called post-traumatic growth, which says that people who endure trauma see some positive growth after. that they somehow become kinder or wiser. And you argue against that. So can you talk about that a little bit? I do. And it's an absolutely critical distinction. Right before my book came out, I had a summary of it published in Wall Street Journal. And you know, you get emails. And right away got an email. And a person said, you are such an idiot. You are, you are pro-suffering. And she said, I live with chronic pain.
好吧，让我们谈谈选择的苦难和未选择的苦难之间的区别。可怕的事情一直在发生。人们生病。他们是暴力的受害者。他们的亲人去世。有一个理论变得很流行，叫做“创伤后成长”，它说经历创伤的人在之后会看到一些积极的成长。他们以某种方式变得更善良或更明智。而你反对这一点。所以你能谈谈那个吗？我反对。这是一个绝对关键的区别。在我的书出版之前，我在《华尔街日报》上发表了它的摘要。你知道，你会收到电子邮件。我立刻收到了一封电子邮件。一个人说，你真是个白痴。你，你支持苦难。她说，我带着慢性疼痛生活。
How can you, you be so cruel to say that my life is benefiting from my suffering? And I wrote to her right back and said, you know, I know there's a distinction there, which I actually make, which is chosen suffering, I think, has a lot of benefits and there's a lot of value. Unchosen suffering is a very mixed back. Unchosen suffering. And, you know, we're living in a pandemic. There's plenty of unchosen suffering around. But it's by no means clear unchosen suffering has to benefit of chosen suffering. Now, when I say this, I bump up against people and, you know, some really respected scholars, psychologists, psychiatrists who say, no, very often unchosen suffering the death of a child, a serious illness, something your house burns down, you lose your job,
你怎么能如此残忍地说我的生活从我的苦难中受益？我立刻回信给她说，你知道，我知道那里有一个区别，我实际上也提到了，那就是选择的苦难，我认为有很多好处，有很多价值。未选择的苦难是一个非常混合的包。未选择的苦难。而且，你知道，我们生活在大流行中。周围有很多未选择的苦难。但未选择的苦难绝不一定有选择的苦难的好处。现在，当我这么说时，我与人发生冲突，你知道，一些非常受人尊敬的学者、心理学家、精神病学家说，不，很多时候未选择的苦难，孩子的死亡、严重的疾病、你的房子被烧毁、你失业，
has benefits. They call it post-traumatic growth to distinguish it from post-traumatic stress disorder. But I got to say, I'm a skeptic. I review a literature in my book saying that, although people often think that bad experiences make them stronger, and I'd be crazy to. to deny that in some cases a bad experience could make you stronger. People are complicated. There's no regular rule that bad things are good for you. The good news is we seem to be very resilient. Bad things don't hurt us as much as we often think they will. But bad experiences are actually, for the most part, not good for us. And to say otherwise is wishful thinking. And I also think it's, I think it's something important to get right. Because if you're wrong and you tell
有好处。他们称之为“创伤后成长”，以区别于“创伤后应激障碍”。但我必须说，我是一个怀疑论者。我在书中回顾了文献，说虽然人们经常认为糟糕的经历使他们变得更强大，如果我否认在某些情况下糟糕的经历可以使你变得更强大，那我就疯了。人是复杂的。没有规律说坏事对你有好处。好消息是我们似乎非常有韧性。坏事对我们的伤害并没有我们通常认为的那么大。但糟糕的经历实际上，在很大程度上，对我们没有好处。说反话是痴心妄想。而且我也认为，我认为这是一件需要正确对待的重要事情。因为如果你错了，你告诉
people, oh my gosh, your kid died. Well, I'm sure there's a lot of growth going to happen. It sets up unrealistic and unfair expectations. I think a better thing to say is that's horrible. And I hope you, it's going to take you time, but I hope you recover. And isn't it a case of people sort of rationalizing to themselves in a sense? Because there's no way to turn the clock back and make it not happen. You can't compare. My life went this way or my life went that way. It's going the way that it's going. And so you've got to find some meaning from a terrible thing that happened to you. That's right.
人们，哦天哪，你的孩子去世了。嗯，我相信会有很多成长发生。这设定了不切实际和不公平的期望。我认为更好的说法是，那太可怕了。我希望你，这需要时间，但我希望你恢复。这难道不是人们在某种意义上对自己进行合理化的情况吗？因为没有办法让时钟倒转，让它不发生。你无法比较。我的生活是这样走的，或者我的生活是那样走的。它正朝着它正在走的方向发展。所以你必须从发生在你身上的可怕事情中找到一些意义。没错。
And in some way, you could be viewed as what psychologists call cognitive dissonance or Dan Gilbert calls the psychological immune system, which is a healthy mind when faced with some bad news, tries to make a good news, tries to say, well, I'm sure there's an upside to this. And I'm not sure it's bad to sort of come in with that attitude. But I think this belief is largely a cognitive illusion, that in fact, bad things. often don't have upsides. Be nice if it were so, but it's for the most part not true. So it's been a lot of discussion recently about how politically polarized the United States is right now and even in the face of a traumatic event like the COVID-19 pandemic. How unusual is this when
在某种程度上，你可以被视为心理学家所说的“认知失调”或丹·吉尔伯特所说的“心理免疫系统”，即一个健康的头脑在面对一些坏消息时，试图制造好消息，试图说，嗯，我相信这有一个积极的一面。我不确定带着这种态度进入是坏事。但我认为这种信念在很大程度上是一种认知错觉，事实上，坏事往往没有积极的一面。如果真是这样就好了，但它在很大程度上不是真的。所以最近有很多关于美国现在政治极化程度有多严重的讨论，即使在面对像COVID-19大流行这样的创伤性事件时也是如此。当
communities experience suffering together like in a pandemic or a natural disaster? Does it usually bring people together or does it usually tear them apart? It depends on the crisis. So a lot of people, include some friends of mine when this pandemic began, said, well, here's the silver lining, which is there's an excellent historical record that when bad things happen to people, it brings them together. It fosters a sense of community, of love, of meaning. People give examples of tsunamis and earthquakes, the 9-11 attacks, the bombing of London during the Blitz in World War II. And they tell, you know, Rebecca Solnit has a wonderful book called A Paradise Built in Hell, where she talks about how these things give meaning to community. And she said, this is, in some way, here's a silver lining of a pandemic. We're all going to come together.
社区一起经历苦难时，比如在大流行或自然灾害中，这有多不寻常？它通常会把人们聚集在一起，还是通常会把他们撕裂？这取决于危机。所以很多人，包括我的一些朋友在大流行开始时说，嗯，这就是一线希望，因为有一个极好的历史记录，当坏事发生在人们身上时，它会把他们聚集在一起。它培养了一种社区感、爱和意义。人们举出海啸和地震、9-11袭击、二战期间伦敦大轰炸的例子。他们告诉，你知道，丽贝卡·索尔尼特有一本精彩的书叫《地狱中的天堂》，她在书中谈到了这些事情如何给社区带来意义。她说，这在某种程度上，这就是大流行的一线希望。我们都会聚在一起。
But the problem is, this doesn't work for pandemics. Stories of the Spanish flu suggest that during that time, people just got mean. They didn't form communities. They were increasingly antagonistic towards immigrants. And there was not much positive because, what happens in this sort of crisis is it isolates us. What we are doing, we are not dealing with COVID by gathering the streets and celebrating or keeping a stiff upper lip as, you know, the bombs fall from above. We're all sitting at home ordering from Uber Eats and staying by ourselves. It's isolating. I wish it weren't so, but not all crises lead to this sort of solidarity and growth. This one certainly has not. And, you know, this one, And this is not something I study, but just an observation seems to have fueled political polarization rather than dampened it.
但问题是，这不适用于大流行。西班牙流感的故事表明，在那段时间里，人们变得很刻薄。他们没有形成社区。他们对移民越来越敌对。而且没有多少积极的东西，因为，在这种危机中发生的事情是它孤立了我们。我们正在做的事情，我们不是通过聚集在街上庆祝或在炸弹从天而降时保持坚强来应对COVID。我们都坐在家里从Uber Eats订餐，独自待着。这是孤立的。我希望不是这样，但并非所有危机都会导致这种团结和成长。这一次肯定没有。而且，你知道，这一次，而且这不是我研究的东西，但只是一个观察，似乎加剧了政治极化，而不是抑制了它。
But let's switch gears for a minute here. Your previous book was called Against Empathy. And in it, you made a counterintuitive argument that empathy is often a bad thing, that it's a bad basis for making moral decisions. Can you talk a little bit about that idea? Yeah. A friend of mine tells me that my books are sort of everything. that looks good is bad and everything that looks bad is good. But I stand by my anti-empathy argument.
但让我们在这里换个话题。你之前的书叫《反对同理心》。在书中，你提出了一个反直觉的论点，即同理心通常是一件坏事，它是做出道德决策的糟糕基础。你能谈谈那个想法吗？是的。我的一个朋友告诉我，我的书有点像“所有看起来好的东西都是坏的，所有看起来坏的东西都是好的”。但我坚持我的反同理心论点。
I have to begin with the most boring of all ways, which is by defining my terms, because some people use the term empathy to mean understanding other people, and I'm in favor of that. And some people use empathy simply to mean being good, being kind, being loving, being a mensch, and I'm in favor of that.
我必须以最无聊的方式开始，那就是定义我的术语，因为有些人使用“同理心”这个词来指理解他人，我赞成这一点。有些人使用同理心仅仅指善良、仁慈、有爱心、做一个好人，我赞成这一点。
But there's a sense which a lot of psychologists use it, and a lot of people use it, which is feeling the pain of another person. and, you know, to say, and a lot of people say, well, to be empath, to be a good moral person, you have to feel the world as others feel it. And I argue that this is a horrible moral guide. And I have many arguments, but the main argument I give is that there's a million studies plus common sense that tell you that you're, it's most natural to feel empathy for somebody you look like or someone's a member of your tribe or speaks the same language.
但很多心理学家使用它，很多人使用它，有一种感觉，那就是感受另一个人的痛苦。而且，你知道，去说，很多人说，嗯，要成为一个同理心的人，要成为一个好的道德人，你必须像别人感受世界那样感受世界。我争辩说这是一个可怕的道德指南。我有许多论点，但我给出的主要论点是，有数百万项研究加上常识告诉你，你，对你看起来像的人或属于你的部落或说同一种语言的人感到同理心是最自然的。
I can naturally feel tremendous empathy for other. professors in my department, for my wife and my kids, for other my neighbors. But we don't naturally feel empathy for people who are afraid of or who don't look like us or speak a different language or live in another country. And fortunately, I argue, we have other moral resources. We have compassion. We have love. And we have rationality. And even though I might not feel empathy for somebody in a faraway land or for someone whose political views differ from my own, I can understand their people just like me and I could extend my natural compassion towards them. So given that you seem to have an affinity for making counterintuitive arguments, where do you go next?
我可以自然地对我们部门的其他教授、我的妻子和孩子、我的邻居感到巨大的同理心。但我们不会自然地对我们害怕的人，或者看起来不像我们的人，或者说不同语言的人，或者住在另一个国家的人感到同理心。幸运的是，我认为，我们有其他的道德资源。我们有同情心。我们有爱。我们有理性。即使我可能不会对远方的人或政治观点与我不同的人感到同理心，我也可以理解他们是像我一样的人，我可以将我自然的同情心延伸到他们身上。那么，鉴于你似乎对提出反直觉的论点有亲和力，你接下来要去哪里？
What are you looking at now? I'm currently working on a book, which is introduction psychology, but not a textbook, not a book for the classroom, but a popular book that somebody just interested in psychology could pick it up. And the subtitle right now is an opinionated terror of the mind. So I'm sure there's going to be parts where I'm going to tell you what seems to be good as bad, vice versa. But I don't expect this one to be particularly controversial, as I hope not. I would think that you'd have quite an audience for it. I mean, what we find at the American Psychological Association is a great deal of interest on the part of the general public in understanding more about psychology and how it works, what it does. Well, as my grandmother would say from your mouth, the God's ear.
你现在在看什么？我目前正在写一本书，是心理学导论，但不是教科书，不是给课堂用的书，而是一本大众书，任何对心理学感兴趣的人都可以拿起来读。目前的副标题是“对心灵的固执己见的恐惧”。所以我肯定会有一些部分，我会告诉你什么看起来是好的其实是坏的，反之亦然。但我预计这一本不会特别有争议，我希望不会。我想你会为它拥有相当多的读者。我的意思是，我们在美国心理学会发现，公众对了解更多关于心理学及其工作原理、作用有很大的兴趣。嗯，正如我祖母会说的，从你的嘴里，到上帝的耳朵。
Well, thank you so much for joining us today. Dr. Bloom, this has been really interesting, and I wish you great good luck with your upcoming book. Thank you. Thank you so much, and this has been a wonderful conversation. I really appreciate you having me here. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Stitcher, Spotify, or wherever you get your podcasts. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at Speaking of Psychology at APA.org. That's Speaking of Psychology, all one word, at APA.org. Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman.
好吧，非常感谢你今天加入我们。布鲁姆博士，这真的很有趣，我祝你即将出版的书好运。谢谢。非常感谢，这是一次精彩的谈话。我真的很感谢你邀请我来这里。你可以在我们的网站speakingofpsychology.org或Apple、Stitcher、Spotify或任何你获取播客的地方找到《心理学谈话》之前的剧集。如果你有对未来播客的评论或想法，你可以发电子邮件给我们：Speaking of Psychology at APA.org。那是Speaking of Psychology，一个词，at APA.org。《心理学谈话》由李·韦纳曼制作。
Our sound editor is Chris Condihan. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的声音编辑是克里斯·康迪汉。感谢您的收听。代表美国心理学会，我是金·米尔斯。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。